a celebration after being cleared of all
charges
Evelyn Hernandez has become the face of
a call to decriminalize abortion in El
Salvador
she faced up to 40 years in prison in a
retrial after giving birth to a
stillborn baby prosecutors accused her
of aggravated homicide the 21 year old
said she was raped and didn't know she
was pregnant today there was justice I
want to thank all the countries and
international organization that
supported me I also want to thank my
mother who stood by me I know it was
difficult for her to see me being
accused of something I didn't do her
case has been fought in court for years
Evelyn was first sentenced to prison in
2017 but was released years later while
she awaited a ruling in her retrial with
17 other women behind bars under similar
circumstances her legal team says the
work is far from over
women who have been in prison for ten
years for something that isn't a crime
we will keep fighting for their release
the case brought international attention
to El Salvador strict abortion laws a
full ban was implement in the Central
American country in 1998 including in
cases of rape or incest women who go to
public hospitals after a miscarriage are
sometimes accused of murder and charged
with aggravated homicide we cannot allow
this to continue we have to change the
law we have to change the enforcement of
the law and we have to free the women
who are still in prison after spending
nearly three years in prison
Evelyn says she's ready to move on with
her life out of court
Katya Lopez over Y on al Jazeera